what happens if donald trump gets
indicted gets criminally charged we've
already talked about how do you even put
together a jury
uh where do you prosecute such a case
all of the different political questions
but one of the other important questions
is do his supporters become violent if
trump is indicted
joe walsh believes the answer is yes joe
walsh is a former republican congressman
not a pro-trump congressman who has
spoken extensively he's been on my show
as well he's spoken out extensively
about what is effectively the trump cult
he was recently interviewed by
salon.com's chauncey de vega and he
sounds the alarm and he says if indeed
there is such an indictment
you will see many trump cultists become
violent he in fact says quote
there is a percentage of trump's
followers who would become violent there
would be a major uptick in violence from
the right around this country if donald
trump was indicted he is their cult
leader they would see it as the deep
state going after their leader there
would be major violence he is 100
correct and you might say but they claim
to be about law and order they always
criticize what they believe is antifa
blm and others
uh rioting as they love to say
how is it that they would be this
hypocritical well that's very easy and
i'm going to tell you in one moment
exactly how they will justify it first
real quick i want to tell you about our
sponsor today policy genius i can tell
you firsthand as someone who has life
insurance you get a significant feeling
of relief from knowing that you're
covered there's really no way to replace
the feeling of knowing that your
family's finances are protected mortgage
payments and other types of debt don't
disappear if something happens to you
even if you have coverage through your
job most people don't have nearly enough
and often needs
the needs are 10 times what the company
provides in terms of life insurance and
typically life insurance gets more
expensive as you get older so
get a policy in place sooner than later
you'll save money policy genius is an
insurance comparison website makes it
super easy to compare quotes from top
companies like aig and many others all
in one place to find your lowest price
couldn't be more easy click the link in
the description or go to policy genius
dot com slash david pakman show answer a
few questions about yourself and you'll
get those quotes you could save fifty
percent or more on life insurance by
comparing quotes with policy genius and
their team of experts will ensure that
you get the right policy that you
understand that they handle everything
for you and it is free to use head to
policygenius.com
david pakman show to get your free life
insurance quotes just see how much you
could save
okay so
republicans trump republicans some
portion would undoubtedly become violent
if trump is indicted they will take to
the streets they will do property crime
they will do property destruction they
they probably will do violence against
individuals as well but they say they're
for law and order they say when antifa
riots it's bad even though they can't
point to one anti-variety they say when
black lives matter riots it's bad even
though they struggle to point to when
that happened how will they justify
they will say
less articulately
with less nuance
that although they are generally
speaking opposed to violence
when there are extraordinary
circumstances extraordinary measures are
required and they will say look this is
a multi-year
theft of our democracy donald trump won
and then it was stolen from him and then
donald trump did nothing wrong other
than say hey it was stolen from me
and then they charged him and we must
rebel because this is the tyrannical
government we always talk about and blah
blah blah yadda yadda so if you think
we're going to be able to get them on
the double standard of saying they're
against violence
and then doing the violence oh no no no
no they will be very very much ready for
that now i hope and listen i still am
very skeptical that there's ever going
to be charges against donald trump it's
just very hard for me to imagine that
i'm hopeful that if and when there is a
day
where charges will be announced
i hope
that the prosecuting attorneys
the district attorney
the courthouse building out of which
this prosecution will take place all of
it
i hope that they are ready in advance to
protect all of the people involved
because they're going to need it they're
going to need it there's no question
that the violence is going to be bonkers
if that happens will it be worse than
january 6th
in some ways it probably will
january 6th was not primarily about
attacking people
january 6 was primarily about
invading and trespassing at the capitol
and messing it up
and it just so happened that they ran
into resistance from dc police and there
was violence but it didn't seem like the
main point was necessarily that although
there were elements of it hang mike
pence being one of them and they didn't
get to mike pence
if trump is indicted my senses that it
will be much more overtly about violence
against people
it remains to be seen
i hope they're prepared but i think joe
walsh is completely correct the trumpest
will get very violent if trump's
indictment day ever comes if you
disagree with me let me know in the
comments